it is so wonderful to see melissa and
chris hi hello
you too you know what uh teary-eyed
watching this film especially as a
mother it's not easy such a heavy
subject to to follow in this film and
it really does make you think about how
you grieve and uh i wonder when you take
out a project like this do you think
about how you actually grieve i mean
melissa are you similar to
lily
no
i'm i'm really um i'm a wreck i i'm a
i'm a very fast and frequent crier
i process
almost er not immediately but i can't
like
which is such a tool people use of that
sense of denial but it's
it's such an unimaginable pain
that it it does make sense that someone
would just go into a state of i must
move forward
i must not acknowledge this because of
almost a fear
i often thought for for lily and
you know i thought for fear of if i face
it it'll break me for good
and i think it's
it's it's such a big part of the story
that i loved is that it didn't break
these people
they were broken but it didn't break
them forever and they did get on the
other side of it and
i think to be able to show the humor
through the tears that's real life you
know it's things are up and down and
sideways
and i think that that balance that ted
got in the in the final telling of the
story really
it's hard to get through but when you
get through your you you're better
you're better yeah well said chris
i mean in terms of grieving i i don't
know i think maybe i'm getting better as
time goes on there's still an awful lot
of distraction techniques and a lot of
crutches that you use to maybe not deal
with the truth and the emptiness and all
of those things that come from
losing something you love
and i think this this film portrays all
of those like in a funny kind of a way
it's it's it's primarily about two
people grieving but
they go through such they go to all of
the stages of it so you can recognize a
lot of your own behaviors in there
and i think that
i think as you kind of mature very very
slowly as i mature
it seems that i am kind of getting a
little better at it
that's good and melissa i have to know
how would lilly do
at the retreat with masha
i think she'd probably hold her own and
matcha pretty well i don't think lily's
going to push around
such a great you have so much such
amazing projects going on right now and
you know the comedic part of it as well
chris uh you know you bring those
elements to the story all these little
punch line with jokes and it's it's so
wonderful to see uh but there's also
that moment at the end with the bird i
mean i need to know have you ever been
attacked by a bird or an animal
i
i don't know whether i there's
i i haven't really been attacked by an
animal but strangely i used to i used to
do this thing i don't know however i
told you this melissa but when i came
right out of drama school i used to do
this thing where somebody told me when i
was going to all these general meetings
just make sure that they remember you
and so when i would go on general
meetings with casting directors
oh my goodness
i
i decided that i would pretend that i
had just been bitten by a dog
and so
i did
i would kind of come up the stairs in
these like little meeting rooms all over
london and go oh my god did you see the
cocker spaniel
and uh yeah it just went from my ankle
and i would kind of play it out and then
do whatever i was supposed to be doing
there and then move on to the next
meeting and i did it for around a month
and uh eventually i had to stop because
i went in and i did and i was like oh my
god it drew blood like this i just came
and and they said oh my god that's so
weird and i was like i know and they
said because the last time you were here
you were bitten by a dog
oh
my god
heartbroken
i remember telling that story on a talk
show once unlike some of the cotton
directors got in touch with pandora like
you did that to us
that's hilarious i love the exactly how
you wanted to be remembered like i
should have a dog attack me
i mean
that shows how few skills i had in my
disposal
well i was i was in this girl i was
viciously attacked by a cat once
like
like it was the cat had i think they
said the cat was epileptic and it was
before there was a medicine this is what
i was like in fourth grade
and its name was sweetness ironically
and if you pet the cat it was very nice
but you could not walk away with from it
it would be like
and i was like i'm never gonna pet i'm
not gonna i was like trying to get out
to my dad who was standing there with
like a farmer
and this cat literally like a cartoon
all the way up my legs my body my head
all around my scalp back down and before
my dad and this guy could get there it
had gone up and down me twice like a
cartoon
and then the kids and and then for the
next like three months everybody at
school whenever i'd walk into a room
they'd just go
they just saved scratch fever
so that's that's why i'm like this now
[Laughter]
congratulations to the both of you on
the film wonderful talking to both of
you thank you everyone thank you